bristle worms are also known as
polykaetes and they're part of the
segmented worm phylum known as annelids
the name polikit translates in Greek to
many hairs those stiff hairs are called
CT and for most balikits they are
attached to paddle-leg appendages called
the parapodia that Branch off each
segment of the Worm but we can't imagine
that it spends its life crawling around
the sand and feeding on algae or
whatever else it can take a bite out of
you can see this one moving its mouth in
slow motion like a weird pair of pincers
inside clamping down on something and
the movement is even more dramatic in
full speed